[Musica]
mamma mamma che c'è flavio cos'è quello
è un gatto flavio anche se non sembra è
un gatto mamma ho finito i compiti ballo
giocare flavio aspetta dobbiamo prima
vederli insieme mamma ti voglio un sacco
di bene fino a infinito
io di più quante domande quante risposte
quante volte abbiamo noi stessi ricevuto
e dato tante tante domande e risposte
per crescere sono s
e oggi vi parlerò di crescita cresce ad
esempio un bambino appunto flavio sei
anni mio figlio che continuamente mi fa
domande io da lui delle risposte che gli
servono come struttura di base sono
quelle prime informazioni che gli
servono per interagire col mondo col
mondo in cui viviamo
la società in cui ci troviamo però
quelle sono solo delle prime
informazioni
lui in realtà quelle informazioni le
userà come base perché tutto il resto
deriverà dalle sue interazioni col mondo
dagli insegnanti dagli amici dai
compagni la squadra di calcio la piscina
tutto quello che facciamo continuamente
ogni giorno e che lui fa ogni giorno
della sua vita costituisce un
informazione aggiuntiva che modificherà
le informazioni di base e quindi creerà
la sua coscienza e conoscenza del mondo
lo metterà come parte di questa società
bene questo però non vuol dire che noi
ci fermiamo di imparare in nessun
momento della nostra vita
quello che fa l'essere umano e
continuare ad accumulare informazioni
lungo tutto l'arco della sua esistenza
senza mai fermarsi in questo modo
l'essere umano si evolve mamma che cos'è
questo un gatto flavio anche se tutto a
pallonate anche se non lo riconosce
è un gatto se ci pensiamo
in realtà l'uomo tolto dalle
informazioni spogliato dalle
informazioni che riceve ogni giorno non
è altro che emozione non è altro che
pelle quello che in realtà è tolto da
tutta l'infrastruttura sociale bene
in realtà tutto questo non è diverso da
quello che è una macchina fili
collegamenti e poi informazioni
informazioni di base che gli vengono
dati dal scienziato il matematico il
programmatore che il genitore quindi da
quelle informazioni di base però anche
le intelligenze artificiali crescono e
si evolvono grazie al contesto
semplicemente ricevono migliaia milioni
di informazioni ogni giorno a una
velocità pazzesca che continuano ad
accumulare e a modificarle modificandosi
però notiamo come la velocità di
apprendimento e diversa infatti pensiamo
a noi come apprendiamo le cose quanto
tempo ci impieghiamo una cosa banale un
libro un libro che ci piace
un libro che ci piace vuole
continuamente vogliamo continuamente
sapere come va a finire siamo ansiosi di
andare avanti e di conoscere il finale
quindi magari a seconda dei nostri tempi
ci metteremo un giorno 2 ma abbiamo
molta fretta di conoscerlo oppure al
contrario un libro che ci annoia di ci
mettiamo tanto tempo a leggerlo volerci
anche settimane mesi anni forse non lo
finiremo mai questo è ciò che ci
differenzia intanto da una macchina una
macchina non ha preferenze non pensa
quanto è bello questo libro voglio
assolutamente finirlo oppure
mamma mia è una noia mortale lo leggerò
dopo no una macchina non ha questo tipo
di pensiero una macchina un compito devo
leggere questo testo benissimo un altro
enorme differenza è che lei lo legge in
millisecondi
mentre noi abbiamo detto impieghiamo un
certo tempo ad accumulare delle
informazioni ea farle nostre la macchina
ci mette millisecondi anche il computer
più banale quello che abbiamo a casa
porta avanti un compito però questa
velocità di apprendimento ricade anche
nel bene e nel male infatti un bambino
impiegherà parecchio tempo e parecchi
informazioni e pechi interazioni col
mondo per accumulare un esperienza e
quindi potenzialmente pregiudizi
informazioni sbagliate negative
impiegheranno parecchio tempo a fa
strada nella sua coscienza
una macchina velocemente apprende nel
bene e nel male quindi velocemente
ricevendo milioni e milioni di
informazioni può assumere degli aspetti
dei comportamenti dei pregiudizi
qualcosa di negativo
all'interno facciamo subito un esempio
era il 2016 quando microsoft rilasciò al
mondo thai boxe thai bot
era un intelligenza artificiale
rilasciata sulla rete con informazioni
di base
queste informazioni le servivano per
interagire su twitter con chiunque
volesse comunicare con lei ed è libera
di comunicare con loro di apprendere da
loro cosa successe che in sole sole 24
ore dei bot
divenne una nazista rispondeva male
diceva parolacce e riceveva parolacce
aveva imparato molto rapidamente dal
mondo
le cose peggiori naturalmente questo fu
un segno di imbarazzo un po per
microsoft è il progetto fu chiuso
rapidamente appunto in meno di 24 ore
dopo centinaia di migliaia di messaggi e
di follower mamma ho finito i compiti
vado a giocare aspetta controlliamo cosa
hai fatto prima
anche le macchine hanno bisogno di
essere controllate corrette e sono le
persone che le modificano dando le
informazioni e le persone che leggono
con nuove informazioni
facciamo adesso un passo indietro nel
tempo
io con mio padre
impara a guidare qualcosa di abbastanza
naturale ai nostri tempi
eppure se ci pensate è qualcosa di
estremamente difficile da l'una
dall'altra parte per chi insegna e per
chi impara perché chi insegna deve
riuscire a frammentare delle istruzioni
delle informazioni che ormai ha fatto
talmente proprio che non riesce a
scomporle i movimenti
eppure deve riuscire a dire metti la
marcia poi la marcia cell e al cielo e
aspetta fa e la pena
ecco tutto questo dall'altra parte chi
impara diventa ancora più complesso
perché riceve istruzioni che non capisce
e che deve mettere subito in moto con
mettere subito in pratica perché
altrimenti mette sotto qualcuno voglio
assicurarvi non ho messo sotto nessuno
all'epoca ce l'ho fatta
eppure è stato molto complesso ripenso a
questa scena nel futuro
io e mio figlio flavio l'uno accanto
all'altro in macchina ma starò
insegnando a mio figlio a guidare no
probabilmente no sarà la macchina che
stava guidando da sola avrà imparato con
centinaia di migliaia di interazioni di
tutti noi che sappiamo già guidare
l'avremo in qualche modo istruita vedete
questa
una macchina che sta imparando a guidare
da sola driver in training sta imparando
da chi guida e da chi cammina cosa
resterà a me ea mio figlio guardarci
intorno
imparare cose nuove scambiare quello che
siamo senza di infrastruttura delle
conoscenze quindi emozioni nuove
interazioni nuove interazioni sociali
quel mondo che potremmo scambiarci che
potremo raccontarci che potremo passare
ai nostri figli a nuove persone ad altre
realtà e queste stesse persone
serviranno ad istruire nuove macchine a
inventare nuovi scenari e quindi a
modificare ulteriormente quello che
siamo noi tutti ogni giorno mamma ti
voglio bene fino infinito io di più
flavio e questo è qualcosa che ancora
oggi le macchine non possono imparare
grazie
[Applauso]